[Music]
hello
i think it's going on
right now
we're live
looking at myself looking at myself
uh so the day is
june 19th
2022
we're all chilling here
the green screen is
just there
it looks all [ __ ] up and [ __ ]
but this is the green screen for now
uh let's get a good big image
let's just sit in it
open image a new tab
this is tiny
this is grainy
google images is so stupid
it's not ideal
there we go an image that's actually an
image
it's good to be here in austin texas
we're hanging out we're having a good
time it's a hot day i should be out
enjoying life but i'm here
just
exploring my thoughts and ideas
with strangers on the internet
um
so i did uh two shows in dallas recently
if y'all don't know dallas is a city in
texas beautiful city
sprawled out so many highways
not very efficiently designed but you
know they make it work they still have
cool people there doing cool things
doing whatever they want to do
talked about gun control oh yeah i don't
have a shirt on
um
i uh you know this is my natural state
you know this is our natural state so
this is just how we should all be we
should all be sort of shirtless uh did
two shows you know
went out met the people performed comedy
had a good time enjoyed my life
did a bunch of cool things um but yeah
had a good time and now i'm back just
killing it
just headlining different places selling
out
enjoying life and stuff
but yeah i mean shirts are overrated
they are not that important
you can live a good life without a shirt
um and i think it's important to live
life without a shirt sometimes
okay
um but yeah what uh what's going on
rooftop koreans as a reference to the la
riots when the police would not enforce
the laws or help out the citizens in
danger and said they would just sit in
beverly hills where there was no danger
uh
just protecting the white people from
potential danger but not actually
protecting the people who were in danger
who were the middle class
the lower middle class the korean
minority
they were instead protecting the whites
because the police don't really give a
[ __ ] about anything but their own
um
personal aggrandization and
capital so they weren't protecting
koreans during the riots black people
mostly
which uh you know i don't blame them but
they were ransacking and looting and
koreans would get on rooftops and use
their uh
advantage of having owned buildings to
shoot at the looters and rioters
uh real middle class versus lower class
battle going on while the real culprits
were sitting getting protected by the
cops
sipping their champagne and watching as
their city burned down as the inevitable
consequence of
economic poverty and police
uh
police occupation
of their city was playing out in front
of them
um but yeah i mean it's cool to protect
your [ __ ] a lot of people jerk off to
that that's important to a lot of people
to be able to protect themselves and
they they're like oh i'm going to
protect myself like this or that
but you know it's not really the best
part
of
korean-american history
it's a sad part it's a sad thing that
the city was so
uh out of control that they had to
resort to that and that the police were
so
uh racist and ineffective
that they had to uh protect themselves
it's better if the government is in
charge of violence but the government
um
does not use violence correctly it only
uses it for
the preservation of whites
um for the most part
um but uh yeah i mean i think the police
have a lot of uh faults but i do think
that uh
the concept of police is nice i guess
hey to the 22 other people in here
listening to hans get all racist on us
what's your take treating your job like
a job but just a means to an end to get
more money and be dispassionate or chase
your passion even if it means you won't
make as much money what matters more
um treating your job like a job and just
living your life for your job is what
cows and peasants in the 1400s england
did
and you don't remember any of them
because they are dead they are gone and
they contributed nothing
uh to the world maybe they their family
is still alive but i would rather do
something more meaningful with my life
than just uh the bare minimum and just
keeping the system going
um
i think that
peasants are very important but
you shouldn't
encourage that you should try to get
more than peasants
i happen to have wanted to do comedy
which you know it might not get really
a lot of uh historical importance i mean
i'm just
making fun of things and being
humorous hopefully but you know it's
still like speaking to
the cosmos and the larger things at hand
i'm not just trying to make other people
more money
i
i think that the purpose of a person
should be to make a lasting contribution
and not just to
uh get by and barely survive we have
we're in a modern time we have the
ability to survive surviving is not hard
if you're just surviving then you're
wasting your time you could have just
survived 200 5 000 years ago
right now we have the technology to
actually express ourselves and to use
all that technology to just get barely
get by is a waste that's not the kind of
world that we live in
we live in a world where we have the
ability to be the best humans that we
can be with the technology at hand
it's just the wealth isn't distributed
evenly and so
a lot of people aren't able to do that
but we should be able to do that and we
should strive to getting the wealth to
be more equal so that we can all do that
um
but yeah since we live in 2022
and
we don't need to just
focus solely on surviving just to
survive i would say i would encourage
people to actually get out there and
make a difference and shine as bright as
you can hopefully not in a violent
destructive way but in a positive way
and uh yeah i mean if you can't i mean
it's like
you're not gonna die like this is a
pretty
easy time to survive i mean you could
always live in your van you could always
there's always
things that you could do i mean there's
a lot of people that are suffering right
now because of wealth inequality but
if you
can survive in 1400s if you can survive
in the woods you can do that same
foraging technique inside of a
goddamn modern society scrounge for
starbucks find coffee lids and lick them
uh find a way to survive there's plenty
of resources here that we could
uh figure it out
would you rather take an inch off your
meat and add it to your height or take
an inch off your height and add it to
your meat
um i mean these are the kind of
questions that sort of don't really
matter um
they sort of like
make you think about things that don't
really need to be thought about
but what is more important height or
dick length i mean when is that ever
going to come up unless you're trying to
[ __ ] a tall person or a big dick person
and i'm straight so i don't need to
really worry about that
but what do i have anxiety about and
what do i have insecurities about my
height or my dick size
i would say more my dick size
i think my height is good
um
you know and if you live
longer it helps to be shorter
so there's your answer
how much for your vans probably 20k
you know 20k you can live in a van
my van
but i like my van i like driving it
around i like having it it's a little
too hot to do anything in it but when
the weather is just right it's perfect
and
you can just
stay in it you can sleep if you're out
and you're just tired you can just go in
there and sleep
uh
if you want some privacy you can get in
there if you want to smoke if you want
to have some freaky time with the lady
you can get in there
it's just a nice thing to have like a
room to yourself no matter where you go
so i like that
um communism is a fool's errand uh the
thing i like about communism is rights
for workers which we have a serious lack
of in america and we need more communism
and less people with capital getting
more and more rich
we have
you know thrown out communism so
like anything that's associated with
communism we [ __ ] hate
out of just uh brainwashing by the rich
people they're like communism is bad
keep giving us money so we're like yeah
we hate communism and then we don't have
any rights and we have no maternity
leave we have no
um
living wage we have a predatory college
loaning money loaning thing
[Music]
i'm 33 years old
um
stop talking about society all the time
not fun or funny imagine if we lived in
a society that was fun and funny and
then talking about society wasn't a
depressing thing i'd rather not turn my
brain off to live in a society
and be happy you know my happiness isn't
that important i don't need to feel
happy all the time i can feel sad i have
the ability to feel sad
so um you know it's like society sucks
and we should admit it and then if we
all feel bad then things will change
but yeah i mean if you'd rather ignore
society and just like pretend you live
in an awesome place just so you can have
cheap thrills and feel good about
yourself it's gonna bite you in the ass
it's not a realistic way to look at the
world we live in and it's uh
you know it's not healthy
it's gonna make your life worse overall
i think i'd rather be aware and just
making fun of [ __ ]
but um
yeah i mean i uh i think that uh overall
that people should be more focused on
making a difference in the world i mean
i
have a journey of where i was in college
and i was disillusioned with the world
and
didn't really
excel at school or engineering
and this was what
my whole life was about at that point so
i was really depressed i was really sad
i was really insecure i'm not good at
the only thing that society can get from
me
uh
um
if you don't think society sucks you're
not paying attention we could do way
better we're not we are purposely
running a uh horrible society so that uh
people can keep their power that they
have
but yeah i mean i was in school doing
engineering not really excelling at it
being bad at it and then not knowing
what my purpose in life is and then i
decided to start comedy because i was
like well nothing
i want to do in this world uh
there's nothing i want to do in this
world more than just make fun of it
um
but yeah i think that um
and then i was living with my mom so i
was working as an engineer at the
startup getting paid minimum wage
and then i got fired for talking back to
the boss
or one of my bosses and being like i
think i should have three digits our
numbering system and this guy was like
we should have four digits and i was
like no three digits i like three digits
it's more pretty nice
um
i think that um yeah i mean so and then
i got fired from the job and so i
started uh
living with my parents in seattle and
then i started doing stand-up comedy
living with my parents for free
and just doing mics mike's mics 15 mics
a week
20 25 three mics a night doing uh
[ __ ] music open mics where i got 15
minutes
um
okay so i was doing 15 minute mics at
music mics and just doing a lot of time
going up more and more
just trying to excel at my craft
and then uh
i moved to new york
lived in my van
started living in an apartment working
in new york for six months and then i
was like in sunset park where i could
afford rent working in gowanus and just
not having enough time to do what i
wanted to do like i did have time to do
mics but
i mean work is like nine to five and
plus it's energy that you drain
most of the time i was at work i was
just pretending to write an email but
just trying to write jokes
um
[Music]
communism is all about workers rights
that's the whole thing
um
communist china is uh fighting a war
against america because america is
invading every country economically and
trying to make it its [ __ ] and they are
fighting against that
um but uh yeah so i was just [ __ ]
working and working and stuff and then
then i was like i don't want to do this
i'd rather live in a van i started
living in a van in january in new york
during the winter in front of a school
my engine wouldn't start the guy who
sold me the car was a mechanic he want
to fix my car
it took forever to find the title
and then i started living uh in front of
the creek in the cave
and just doing mics all the time and
hanging out and having a good time
um
um
okay yeah
i guess
nobody's gonna [ __ ] me anytime soon
yeah then i was uh i was there just
living life and uh doing mics all the
time new york is a very bitter place you
know people there are nice to each other
and they don't really uh care about
talent
they only care about themselves and
kissing ass and it's just uh
a kiss-assery it's not really a
meritocracy it's a bunch of [ __ ]
um
i think that uh new york is great if you
want to be around other people and stuff
but i think that structure is flawed i
think they're
too much like
the finance world and they don't
they don't have like
i don't know it's not a good culture
over there in my opinion
um
yeah i bet i think that uh then i did uh
then so i just was like pursuing my
craft and just being like i don't give a
[ __ ] about anything else at least if i'm
working on comedy i'm investing in
myself and investing in energy in myself
and making myself a better person every
day
um
um but yeah i mean
can you tell us a good melissa weisman
story she's a friend of mine
uh she's great
other than comedy what other creative
outlets do you enjoy i like music i like
computer games i like settlers of catan
uh i like your uh
i'll be here but you won't know who i am
i'll be the phantom at your opera cool i
mean that's the role that most people
have in a comedy show is that like
they're just sitting there and i don't
really know who they are but that's kind
of the best way to do it because then i
can just perform instead of being
worried about what you think about me
and [ __ ]
but yeah i mean uh i'm used to opera
phantom so i can't wait to see you at my
show skulking and lurking and then
afterwards i usually shake hands and
kiss babies so i hope to meet you there
but yeah dallas was fun i had a great
time met so many people so many people
came out it was an amazing experience
thank you
dallas and all the
fort worth residents and [ __ ]
[Music]
but yeah i mean
i think um communism is just uh
just been like so maligned and like why
was america so against communism from
the beginning
why was uh britain against democracy
and american independence in the
beginning why were the european powers
so against
france and their revolution where they
killed their king in russia where they
killed their king it's because they want
power to rest in the hands of the people
that have it now
they america saw russia
uh being like we should give power to
the people and they were like no we are
giving power to the capitalists and the
rich i don't want you doing this
experiment in case our country's
citizens get the same idea so this
experiment must fail we must pour money
into this because ideologically we hate
what you're doing not because they were
doing war crimes or there were famines
there were famines in india and america
didn't do [ __ ] about that
um there were
genocides and
war crimes being committed by allies of
america they don't give a [ __ ] about
genocides or war crimes the only reason
why they started the cold war and
put the world at risk of nuclear
extermination is because they were
worried about wealth redistribution and
the toppling of an unequal power
structure that they wanted to maintain
unnaturally inefficiently for as long as
possible
um but yeah i mean i think it's really
horrific that america just started a war
because against russia and the soviet
union because they were just like we
don't want
this to work and then they
destroyed it and they're like look it
doesn't work it's just a
stupid thing to do it's
not a sustainable strategy
and uh
now that america has won the cold war we
see
like what their plan was they don't have
a plan they just
want to keep making more money and
colonizing more foreign countries and
making more poor people to work for them
and then they're they're going to
destroy the planet i mean it's not a
i don't think the good guys want the
cold war
this is not a good uh
ideology
is your joke writing processes waiting
for jokes to come to you what happens if
they don't come
i try to write every day you know
writing is important it opens up your
mind and you're like now i'm going to
think about
this [ __ ]
um and try to have jokes come into my
head i also do these for jokes um you
know just thinking talking to people
helps me write jokes
uh but the thing about talking to people
is that you have to take a break and be
like hold on i'm going to write this
[ __ ] so it's just different
i lived in vietnam for 13 years no real
communism but it's a socialist republic
conditions are not good workers actually
do not have rights it's slavery with no
voice for most workers
well vietnamese uh people are under
economic warfare they were bombed and
murdered by americans for no reason
and then they had a war with cambodia
that they had to fight
and also you lived there for 13 years so
it can't be that bad
also um if you think workers rights in
vietnam
[Music]
um need improvement i think it's uh
better to improve
workers rights in vietnam than to be
like this never works we have no ability
to do this maybe it's the fact that uh
the greatest superpower in the world is
oppressing it that uh they don't have
enough resources to go around
um and i just
would like to
[Music]
see that
[Music]
no you don't have to clean slate a
country just try communism uh we just
need to give workers more rights instead
of letting capitalists run our country
and it's like if you just let
capitalists run your country and give
all your money to a foreign company then
your workers are also not going to have
rights check out the workers rights in
el salvador
and
guatemala
and look how poorly people live there
uh you know look how america treats its
allies
now the problem is if you try to say
something you go to jail i wonder why
it's like almost like they're at war
with america the richest superpower in
the world
and uh
like if they have to get their [ __ ]
together to fight off america they can't
have people doing uh
you know being like seditionary
seditious because
they're they're fighting off america
i think that a lot of things that people
hate about communism is just what it
takes to fight off a superpower and
being under economic warfare
orcas worked to build capital their
capitalists by definitions no they don't
own capital they build capital for
capitalists that's not capitalism um but
yeah i mean communism is uh
trying to get workers more rights if
they're not getting workers more rights
if the people aren't getting richer
overall then uh
that's like being like capitalism is
when you jail black people and you have
25 of the world's population in jail
which is sort of capitalism but
yeah i mean uh if they're not doing
communism then why are you criticizing
communist countries for being communist
if they're not giving workers more
rights
if they actually cared about people they
would not sanction countries like cuba
and block food and medicine to the
general population
yeah i mean cuba is uh on the wrong side
of america and america is just [ __ ]
with it but it's cool that they're there
and just like
surviving in a way that uh they're like
right next to america and they're just
like we're gonna do what we want just
leave us alone like that should be every
country and you shouldn't economically
starve them they're an island nation
there's not going to be a lot of
[ __ ] that they can get
you should join bill maher one of his
spots because you have a long head like
vertically yes
i have a long head none of this plays
into my personal life conspiracy but i
can make room for it sure
um yeah i mean it's like how far do you
really want to zoom out
um i mean if workers have more rights
there will be less homeless people
people have more money um
housing will be decommodified and we can
actually [ __ ] fix [ __ ]
they were dumping toxic waste into the
ocean destroying the fish that people
farmed
they allowed people to protest it but it
was a trap to send them to jail well if
you're looking for pollution just look
at capitalism look at the exxon valdez
or fracking
we do a lot more pollution than vietnam
and we're a capitalist country which
should be the best right capitalism is
the best
saying that jailing black people and
what not is what capitalism is is like
that's all failed communist states are
what communism is
well jailing black people is necessary
to capitalism because
you uh want cheaper labor and profit is
all you care about
um
if you want to look at some horrible
protests
uh being squad or a protest being
squashed horribly look at the black
lives matter protest look at all the
people getting shot in the face with
less than lethal rounds
um
but for this case allow them to protest
for three days and they run them up and
send them to prison um
look at uh
you know
how we handled how the police just went
around in trucks just shooting people
um
should we follow singapore's drug policy
um no
i think drugs are cool
um i think that uh singapore is uh you
know they're all business-minded and
they don't have
the creativity and the love of the human
spirit that some americans have
but
yeah i mean i think
we should
you know be more modern
instead of just
not being modern
in terms of career and pursuing your
dream do you think the age of 30 is
young or you should have it all figured
out by then
no you shouldn't
worry about your age you should just be
a person that exists and
i mean you're not competing against
other people you're just competing
against yourself if you can perfect
yourself against yourself then other
people
will
be an easy competition if you can
uh you know excel from yourself that'll
be good great
uh how old are you 33 we need to change
the topic he said he's 33.
um but yeah i mean i think that uh
i think that the biggest thing
uh that uh
i think the biggest thing that we should
take away from
the world
is
that we can do it we can fix it and make
it better instead of just being like it
can't be fixed
i am originally from the west coast and
the east coast i'm originally from both
coasts
uh doing political still you're
hilarious coming and again
dude and i love you i'm gonna go to work
hey sans see you dude sorry you disagree
with me
now they are sanctioning iran and
starving regular people because
if not going along with them
i'm not going to how many times have you
smoked dmt
and how to relax as a first timer
kimchi
um dmt is fun i had a good time you know
um
i don't do too many drugs right now
because i feel like i'm in a good place
i'm in a happy place and i enjoy my life
and i don't want to zonk myself out and
get out of here
um
i think that uh dmt is like it's a good
thing to do i think it's good to make
your brain feel happy and be like
sometimes like when i did like molly or
something
i remember i did molly and then i was
like oh [ __ ] this is what it's like to
be happy i hadn't felt it in a while i
didn't know what it was like and it just
broke my brain out of this
uh rut that i was in where i was just
you know uh whatever i was grumpy i was
like i'm just going through the motions
and i was like oh wait life can be happy
so i think it's good to sort of jolt you
out of
some stuff
biden did fall off his bike uh as a
uh
person who watched the video i have to
say that what i think he did was he had
his foot in the toe hold
and he
tried to take his foot out but he didn't
lift it far enough so he took it out
only a little bit and then he tried to
move to the side he was trying to go
like this this is his foot he's trying
to like this
and then land and his weight was going
over in that direction
but he didn't take his foot out all the
way he only did a little bit like an
ineffectual type of dude like he's like
a [ __ ]
you know like he's he's got he doesn't
have full strokes he doesn't he's an old
man he's got dementia he can't pull his
full out foot out all the way so he
didn't do this he went like this and it
was still in the thing and he was
leaning over and he couldn't just like
sort of lean over the other way he was
just like oh i'm falling and then he
sort of felt like an old dude where he
was just like whoa
like there was plenty of time to react
and like reach out but it was just like
i'm falling and like
it was just like i'm just gonna stand
still because that's what i do in normal
life why would i move around
but yeah i think it was pretty
embarrassing and
you know like that's really important to
the people that hate him is like the
ability to be physically
uh
you know with it and like biden doesn't
have that and like that's like a big
thing to them but people who already
like him they don't really care like
that's not why we elect presidents it's
because they can
uh you know stand up all the time
um but yeah i mean
i think that uh people who you know
might not
really
uh
have
you know an awareness of what the
president does might think that's a
bigger deal than it is
but uh yeah i mean like is that an
important thing like if someone falls is
that a sign that they're a stupid person
like you you're just supposed to go
through life not making mistakes at all
that's the one thing you should do is
like just not make mistakes i think
there there should be more to life
than just not looking like an idiot
because if you just try not to look like
an idiot then you'll never make
something awesome
um but yeah i mean it's it's funny it's
like a goofy thing it's like oh look
this guy that's running our entire [ __ ]
that's
in charge of us all is like [ __ ] up
and being an idiot so i think
that's it's cathartic to a lot of people
it brings joy to people to
notice that our society is falling apart
but i think that
there should be a way to
enjoy joe biden in another way
and that we should figure out how to
elect people who are
uh you know more relevant and more
uh able to fix our economic problems and
the workers rights that we don't have
and uh you know we were scared and we
voted for biden and i think it's um
i think it's just a sign that what we're
doing isn't working and we should do
something else besides the same old
thing that doesn't work
um
a way the way that we're running this
country how we ran it in the 90s and 80s
and 2000s isn't working it's not a
sustainable [ __ ] thing and we just gotta
admit it and be like okay we gotta
actually take care of people instead of
being mean to them to make them work
harder
um i think that we could have a lot more
efficiency and creativity that we're not
having because we look at the world the
way
that we do
um but yeah i mean um this is the boat
that i wish i was on i enjoy uh boating
i think that uh
it's good to
be on the water and it's uh convenient
you know girls love boats they love
being on the water water is something
that they love
uh because it flows and it's like
it's not hard until it is
it's soft until it's not it's like soft
and hard and they're like
it flows and waves around them and it
makes them feel different and goes into
their coochie
um and then and then it cools them down
it
uh softens them up or you know it's good
for hot weather they're
uh justified and wearing skimpy outfits
around water
um
and it uh
it
it's like luxurious like look that all
this water that people are not drinking
in flint i'm just living on
and uh it's just like um
a cool place to party
uh you know you get instant cooling down
effect if you jump in it on a hot day
um
and it's it's an ideal situation for
human beings i mean the aquatic ape we
love
we love the water
most of us
without melanin
uh which living comic would make the
best president
one that would fight for the rights of
workers and not just give all our money
to rich people out of fear
because rich people are holding our
society hostage
and not letting us
have a more fair distribution of wealth
because they control everything and if
we don't give them all our money they're
going to tank the whole thing
so they're holding us hostage and
they're not letting us be who we really
can be and utilizing our full potential
they're keeping us
down and limiting our potential so that
they can continue to maintain their
power
at all costs
um
i would just think that uh presidents
are just
just a figurehead for what the people
want so
why don't we get the people to get what
they want i am cheerless i mean i'm uh
i'm i'm also cheerless i'm a very boring
uh droning communist i guess
but i am shirtless because it is 102
degrees here in texas we're going
through a heat wave
turns out you can't just pump [ __ ] into
the air and not have to deal with the
consequences
when [ __ ] gets
polluted it gets hot
and it is hot it is hot as [ __ ] it's
only june the hottest
day or the hottest time of the year in
austin and most places is the first week
of august
so june
we got 10 more days of june then we got
a whole month
and then another week
so it's gonna just gonna keep getting
hotter from here
uh this is unconscionable and we should
do something about making
our weather more
habitable
we should try to figure out how to
control the weather
but no that's not important what's
important
is continuing our reliance on fossil
fuels so that the current existing power
structure can maintain
its power
um what do you think of
joke writers that are slightly more
formulaic like jiselnik
i mean i think you can use the formula
to express yourself
i think that uh jokes are
a tool that you use to show people who
you are are show people how you find
humor and joy in the world and
um
you know i think it's fine if that's how
that's what you want to do
uh i like
bro it's summertime in tx we've set a
couple daily records
um it's not it's not healthy
but yeah i mean it's pretty hot uh
there's a local climate graph that i
like to look at
um
so let's see how hot has it been
in austin tx
look at this
this is a record right here
you see that [ __ ]
we're right here
this is a record this is right it's
never been hotter than this on this day
i mean it's been hot this day
but uh yeah this is the average and
we're above average
um
but yeah i
mean
it's gonna get hottest right here
in august and we're already
at that level pretty much of the hottest
it's ever been in august right now
um i mean it's not a great trend ideally
you'd want to be
more
in the middle of the green area but hey
look
we went all the way down here
you know
uh it looks a little jumpy a little
schizophrenic right here i don't think
this is a sign of a healthy
healthy ecosystem
and why would we have a healthy
ecosystem we did almost no work to
ensure that we would
um
we are if something is going wrong it's
probably because we spent no time or
effort or energy into making sure that
our planet is doing well
um but uh
you know people are like well i'm not
even a part of society i'm just my own
self um
sorry but you are a part of society
i know you don't like to think you are
because it makes you feel better or
whatever but um really
doesn't matter what you think you are a
part of society and we should all work
to try to make it a better place instead
of just being okay with it being shitty
because
it's not gonna last
um something
snow covered
mountain
wallpaper
i think white shows up better
on my shitty green screen because it's
not lit properly apparently it needs to
be further back
oh my god why is this so [ __ ] tiny
what's with these tiny ass pictures dude
i don't want to go to a [ __ ] website
and
click through a bunch of [ __ ] i have
to scroll and find it
i just want an image that is big and
nice
see it's hard to see it's grainy unless
you're looking right here
this is really specific but i'm going to
start doing open mics in seattle any
tips or does it not matter where you
start as long as the city is big i mean
seattle's a good city i started in
seattle
um yeah you should just keep doing it
and learn and learn about yourself and
grow you know like uh some people are
like i am perfect the way i am and i
don't want to change
um i just need to have people see me i
am not going to get better
uh there's a beautiful part of me that i
need to preserve but if there is a
beautiful part of you that cannot
withstand the scrutiny of improvement
then is it really that beautiful is any
part of you that cannot stand
your
effort and dedication really worth
preserving
if it's worth preserving it'll last if
it's not worth preserving then it'll be
cut out in your
hard work and dedication
and any part of you that you value
should be something that is
uh
obtained through hard work and
dedication and not just something that
uh you happen to have
um
i think those parts of you are the most
basic and
the most boring but that's
not really about you that's just my
general philosophy as an asian about
individualism and like how to be a
better person and all that
um i just think that every part of you
should be open to improvement instead of
just keeping like a national park inside
of your head the size of yellowstone
and then never improving and any of that
because that's me i'm never gonna
improve that
uh if that [ __ ] can't withstand
my ability to get better than i don't
want to
i don't want to keep it around
this is a tough world in my head and
anything any personality trait that
can't survive doesn't deserve to
i don't like your chin
chinese i don't like your chinese well
i'm not chinese and i never speak
chinese i don't know how to speak
chinese i know it's a filthy chinese
game but i'd love to see a mahjong
stream one of these days
i like to see
you [ __ ] your cousin and
eating mayonnaise and
you know
murdering native americans
on your stream i'm assuming you're
white um
yeah i'm having a good time uh are you
saying that people don't have value
unless they work hard
yeah
i'm saying that people don't have value
unless they work hard well you think
that you have value just because you
exist
um
i mean i think the best people are
people that work hard
who's someone that doesn't work hard
that you respect
like
i don't know my mom i respect because
she worked hard raising me uh hot girls
i don't respect
unless they're respectable people
i just think that it's so easy to be a
terrible person when you're hot that
most people choose that it's not
anything against women um it's just like
uh yeah i mean
what who is a person that doesn't work
hard that deserves respect
like a model a fitness model fitness
models work hard just like a hot girl
who happens to be skinny i don't know
i don't know what you're trying to say i
think like in america people are just
like
oh i exist so i should i deserve a lot
of things
disabled people work hard to
survive in the world that they were born
in
they have to work hard or also die so i
respect them
me [ __ ] too
miguel
ii america too miguel means america and
korean
seems like a good launching pad for
comics lately joe fahem
hans joel mikhail jeff probst
um yeah i mean i think um
this idea that there's the best city in
all the other cities are inferior is a
false notion i think to have a healthy
comedy scene you need
seattle you need atlanta you need denver
you need detroit like these comics they
travel all over the country
they're getting a little piece of
minneapolis and michigan and all that
you know like you need the whole thing
the more people that you meet the better
and the more comedy scenes there are the
more people starting in different scenes
there are the more diverse the comedy's
gonna be and the better the stronger the
scene's gonna be you can't just have
everyone just moved to new york and new
york's the only good city in the world
you need that flavor that geographic
thing that you get living between a
river and pittsburgh or
you know the unique
cultural history of san francisco
um
[Music]
you need you know the demographic makeup
of west virginia to make funny jokes
about
um
but yeah there's plenty of people that
work hard that aren't good people but
there's very few good people that don't
work hard if you're a good person why
wouldn't you work hard
why would you be lazy lazy people aren't
good people
um but yeah i mean it's just like
you just want value for just existing
but
you know
mere existence is not praiseworthy in
and of itself no matter what astrology
toting
uh millennials and genders will tell you
yeah i mean i don't think i think that
we work too hard nowadays and a lot of
people work
stupidly
they work hard for a stupid reason they
work hard at jamba juice because
they
think that if someone is paying them
that they must
have some reason and that it must be
important but just because someone is
paying you doesn't mean it's a good
reason to work hard
um
you know just because it's making
a corporation money doesn't mean that
it's worth dedicating your life to and
throwing your life away to sell people
juice
i just think that
hard work has been hijacked
by
rich people to make poor people work
really hard for them what are you lazy
you're a hard worker you want to earn
what you get right well then work 725 an
hour at this auntie annie's
uh
because you're a hard worker and you
deserve awesome things
but yeah i mean you shouldn't have to uh
work hard
uh in terms of like busting your ass for
40 hours a week just to survive i mean
it doesn't cost that much to keep a
person alive
uh it costs way less than that and we're
being exploited out of our time
and energy
uh the exchange rate for our labor is
not fair so i would not sign up for the
labor market it is a waste of time but
yeah hard work has been hijacked by rich
people to make you work hard for them
don't don't work hard for stupid things
part of working hard is picking what to
work for you can't just start working
hard at uh
digging a
big ditch and then expect to get a lot
of rewards for it you got to pick a
hobby that's uh fruitful
like i mean no matter how good you get
it you know finger painting i think
finger painting you can get really good
at
i mean there's a lot of things that have
a lot of potential i mean i happen to
choose comedy chosen comedy
and all that
but um yeah i mean
you got to pick the right thing to work
hard at you can't just
pick the easiest thing or the one that
people
will pay you for because i mean
sometimes it works out but sometimes you
waste your life
working really hard for someone who's
paying you minimum wage
and your life is pointless and you get
nothing out of it
you gotta pick the right thing to work
hard at you can't like if you're working
hard then spend a little bit of that
hard work energy to find out what you're
working for and if it's actually
going to benefit you overall
um if you are working hard and you spend
no time or energy thinking about what
you're doing then you're not really
working hard you're
being a dumb robot or a piece of cattle
americans are trying to pull back on
spending in the face of rising gas
prices u.s retail sales dropped slightly
in may from the previous month that we
were below economics
expectations of a small increase
yeah i mean i guess we're not spending
as much money um
that's good
um you know they say that uh if you give
a rich person a million dollars they'll
just put in their bank account but if
you give a hundred thousand people
and split a million dollars evenly
they'll buy 75 pillows
42 peanut butter jars and that
stimulates the economy more than
that's how the economy is supposed to
function that's actually the purpose of
the economy rather than just to have
rich people
uh hoard it and then
meet it out to their friends and family
and whatever pet projects that they'd
like to fund
um
i'm trying to be a mailman
but they keep denying me because i got
discharged from the air force for weed
gonna keep trying though can you imagine
a society where they're like oh you want
to deliver mail but hey you smoked weed
once
it's like it should be a requirement to
deliver mail
like if you're trying to deliver mail
sober
what kind of person is that that's a sad
person who's just
like the most boring mr rogers
uh kind of person like you need someone
who's like what's up man
yeah just delivering mail dude
i'll totally theory in the managerial
class
i don't really know what that's about
but yeah we have these puritanical ideas
of uh what makes a good person don't
smoke weed
um you know
uh don't swear and like the post office
is kind of an old institution so they're
kind of caught up in all that
um
edgar poe knows a lot about what
americans are spending money on you
don't have to work hard but you should
work well for your own sake imagine not
caring if the ice and the frappuccino is
blended good
well i think that you should be able to
work hard you should
have times in your life where you're
working hard you should have times in
your life where you're relaxing so that
you can work hard later but humans are a
tool and we're best used for a purpose
not just for
uh to be looked at or to have all our
needs met or to have the most comfort
and the most pleasure in the world that
is not
uh our job that's not what we're on here
on earth for is just to feel the best
emotions
what we should do is uh perfect
our ability to do things and accomplish
things and make things happen in the
world
do you ever think about trying
longer jokes than one lighters
well i just simplify and if i can get a
point across simply then i'll try to do
that
um
[Music]
that's true
the other half of us are weed smokers
you know
i'm certainly a giant tool
well joe lloyd is a tool
um i love white people i think white
people are great i just don't think that
they're the master race i don't think
black people are the master race either
even though they are pretty
pretty stout
i got a jet but if it was nice hearing
you pontificate we need more korean
comics
are you korean edgar po this guy is just
spitting out facts this guy's just like
the consumer index and the interest
rates today are 49 and 2.
um but um
yeah i mean
i think white people are great
but i just been hanging around them too
much to think that they're amazing i
don't believe all this talk about them
being the master race i've just hung out
with them too much
they're not that much better
there's white people that are amazing
but
they're just i don't know i hung out
with asians blacks
mexicans even a filipino or two
um
and
it's it's like
they're we're all amazing i mean white
people aren't terrible
i'm not saying that white people are
terrible but i think that uh overall
they're just
they're
they're awesome people just like
everyone
um
so you ever going to come to canada we
will fill a stadium for you
okay
um i think that uh well i recently on
the latest podcast on the latest kill
tony i said that my least three least
favorite races are
sri lankans native americans and black
people
uh sri lankans because i just think that
they're
like
a weird mix of africans and indians they
look like
uh purple
uh and their their eyes are like indian
eyes but their skin is like black
people's skin it's just like
just like a weird hybrid
that doesn't fit my brain because i'm
not used to dealing with them but you
know i love m.i.a
and i love the tamil tigers i love
people fighting for their independence
oh
it's just like if you have to pick
if you have to pick a [ __ ]
group of people that
kind of freaked out by sri lanka the
native americans i've been watching a
lot of yellowstone
and
you know i just don't like them as a
race because they are
um
they have been so maligned but honestly
like all those the the native americans
are the black people i don't like
because of what white people did to them
it's really white people that i don't
like
and they're historical crimes
and uh and the effects of that it lives
out through the minorities that they
affected like native americans are
in a bad state right now and in trailer
parks on reservations in the middle of
nowhere drinking their life away
because of white people i mean americans
and their uh war crimes
during the 1800s
to now and before and all that
and then black people i think uh
are suffering some trauma from [ __ ]
white people being [ __ ] crazy to them
like they brought it seems like
americans brought black people over here
so they could just torture them for fun
it's like what the [ __ ] dude if you hate
them that much why the [ __ ] did you
bring them over here if you're gonna be
this mean to them you should have just
left them alone this is not healthy for
anyone it's not even healthy for you
like you're just it's like a kid that
has like puts a cat in a bag
it's like this is not it's not good
it's not a good relationship you guys
need to figure your [ __ ] out
uh
so what do we do now mr kim
indian feather fisher indian dot may be
more successful but certainly smells
worse
i mean indian people are great i think
indian people
are um also horribly traumatized by
british colonization colonialism
and the famines
and the humiliation and the uh poorly
run
uh thing that they had with the brits
that's on thomas sowell i think that he
is right about some things
uh but i think that he is wrong about
how we should feel about
the whole issue
i think like yeah it sucks that black
people
are like gangsters and they're like
violent and they're aggressive but i
don't think the fault is that black
people chose to be more violent i choose
i think that fault is that they had no
other avenues to express themselves
in a self-affirming way and they had to
do
uh the whole gangster route because that
was the only route available to them
because of white people and segregation
and
their economic [ __ ] being limited
um
yeah
i think
it was a horrible thing
what happened to black people
his views on black culture are kind of
cringe
who are you top three white people of
all time minus tony hawk bob ross jack
black
my favorite whites are
probably um
willie nelson
um
anthony weiner
and
nice ferrari too
so
asians are kind of front runners though
great economics as a people and
personally know how to wear a mask both
physically and metaphorically what do
you mean wear a mask metaphorically
well yeah i mean i guess it's good to be
asian we are
good at living in a society we're polite
we're quiet we're
out of the way
it is bad to be asian because we don't
have any individual personalities we
don't have much creativity we
just uh
grind it out and [ __ ] it up and don't
really
normally figure [ __ ] out
uh it's hard to challenge the norms of a
community but in america it is not
impossible yeah in america people are
like yeah challenge
me i like being challenged and people
like fighting with each other which is
good things sometimes
uh asians are just too docile and too
easily coerced
by
uh
their society
to really
make a difference
if i was to pick on asians
um but yeah i mean i think that uh
asians are just
you know another version of humanity and
we should all be able to tap into
different
uh races at different times like if i am
playing basketball i don't want to tap
into the asian way of being i'd rather
tap into
you know
imagine myself to be a black man
um
yeah it's just
we all it's it's a beautiful world where
we get to
uh
you know
uh learn that about so many different
cultures and ways of life and races like
back in the day we only knew
like not as many races i mean i'm sure
there was a lot of multiculturalism
going back in the past
but uh you know it's good that we have
this ability to know about all these
different races and different options
for humans to be instead of just being
like oh this is the only way i can be
there now there's many different ways
that i know i can be and i can [ __ ]
do that [ __ ]
asian suicide rates are through the roof
seemingly in children due to the home
dynamic but on the surface asians are
particularly very proper employee yeah
isn't that awesome about asians that if
we're not doing good we just take
ourselves out no mess no problem we
don't just stick around just being a
drain on our society we're like okay
i'll see the door
i'm out of here
yeah obvious i'm kidding uh asians are
great with mountain range
is hans kim streaming from
i don't know
this looks
very
hmm i really can't tell
i'm not a real mountain guy
conifers um
i have no idea
let's see
i don't think this even says
they don't even give a [ __ ]
it's just pixels to them they're just
trying to sell wallpapers
but that's been the stream thank you
guys so much for listening and i hope to
see you guys again
and i love you